his force has already claimed the lives
of billions grandma the authority to
change history before Vandal Savage puts
an end to it as a Time Master we possess
no arm I'm not asking for one just to
see me
I specifically said no weapons come left
you have
doesn't a legend have to be dead that's
a deal-breaker for me I chose you eight
to travel throughout time because the
future of the world is in peril
I say we kick some ass
hey guys we have a new and very huge
problem
dc's legends of tomorrow series premiere
thursday january 21st on the CW go out
for one lousy drink and you guys somehow
manage to pick a fight with Boba Fett
hey youtubers is charlie happy new year
brand new legends of tomorrow footage
that totally looks like something out of
Richard Donner Superman or even
something out of Doctor Who rip hunter
goes to see the Time Lords rip hunters
organization is called the time masters
that you know that's straight out of DC
Comics history so it looks like these
first two episodes which is like you
know pilot part one pilot part two are
going to deal with their mythology which
i think is going to be awesome it'll
kind of set it apart from other big DC
organizations the thing that's different
about the time masters like if you've
been a fan of Booster Gold Booster Gold
time-traveling [ __ ] who just helps
people out seems like a douche bag is
that rip hunter is his son from way
further in the future with way more
advanced tech so it's really easy to
fall into that logic trap where you're
like well if they're so powerful and
they're so far in the future you know
why isn't it like doctor why don't they
change time all the time as it suits
them that's part of what this scene is
going to answer because obviously at
this point in history Vandal Savage is
either risen to power or been long dead
it looks like in this version the time
like the first version it's like the
flash season one where berries like wait
my mother wasn't supposed to die I need
to save her but then he goes back in
time and you find out what ends up
happening is a spoiler warning for the
flash season one if you haven't seen it
yet here we go so Barry goes back in
time and finds that his other set like
another version of himself is there and
says don't do it dude do not try and
change the past so right off the bat
they have to explain what Vandal Savage
has done to change history in a bad way
and how did he come back in the first
place because remember at the end of the
arrow flash crossover he was a pile of
ashes everybody starts shaking your fist
and screaming Barrowman because you know
obviously Malcolm Merlyn did something
to save him we'll probably find out what
that is really quick because usually
that's the way they open with big things
like this like when history needs to be
changed usually they show you the big
WTF to lead things off where it's like
oh my god this wasn't supposed to happen
and then you jump to scenes like this
where someone from the future is like
hey wait hey guys can we change this
because we are totally effed if we don't
but if you are doctor who fan you know
that they don't use the Time Lords a
whole lot usually you're just following
the doctor in his companion running
around having adventures so most of this
series is just going to be rip hunter in
all the heroes will probably check in
with the time masters every once in a
while the way I think about all powerful
organizations like that is kind of like
the Suicide Squad dynamic where it's
like you you have a ragtag group of
people who might not necessarily all be
heroes so usually they end up being the
protagonists and people like Amanda
Waller or the time masters end up
seeming more like villains than the
actual villains now that's not exactly
what's going on I wouldn't say that's
the exact characterization of the time
masters but anybody who is all powerful
is just a little bit sinister you can't
have that much power and not seem a
little bit evil but the other big thing
that's going on in this clip is it's
just showcasing some of the humor of the
series we go out for one lousy drink and
you have to piss off Boba Fett now I
think they go back to the 70s in the
first episode that's probably just right
out of that 70's bar fight that they get
into that they've been posting in all
the trailers the way they present it
though and makes it seem like the white
canary is the one that picked the fight
with Boba Fett which I which I totally
love like normally you'd expect heatwave
big huge mentally unstable bro dude to
start all kinds of bar fights but the
canary is just like that too she still
has a little bit of bloodlust dinner so
I think they've been using that energy
in a really fun way oh you know although
technically there is the scene that she
has with Laurel worlds like it's time
for you to step into the light you've
been this really dark assassin figure
you were part of the League of Assassins
now it's time to be this hero in the
light of day it's kind of like the same
thing that's going on with Oliver Queen
right now where he's like I need to be
someone who's a hero during the date not
just at night but caity lotz his
character is just way too much fun when
you let her off the leash I love the
captain cold is the one that objects to
getting in fights like that too whoa
everybody just chill out and then
there's that great line where it's like
hey wait a minute don't legends have to
be dead before they get called legends
that's kind of a deal breaker for me so
if you're one of those people that
really likes the way they use humor on
the flash like the cisco character with
you know crazy one-liners I feel like
this series is just turning that up to
11 like the crazy comic book level you
wish all comic book TV shows could get
to so just reminder in case you didn't
see my Suicide Squad video there's like
a whole bunch of stuff happening January
nineteenth the twentieth and
twenty-first January nineteenth the
flash comes back that's episode 10 right
after that they're doing a legends of
tomorrow half hour special just like oh
my God look at this show it's going to
be so amazing then they're doing a
Suicide Squad Batman V Superman special
they're going to post new footage from
Wonder Woman new footage from Suicide
Squad just be sure to keep watching
after the flash
at night arrow is the next night arrow
episode 10 comes back and then on
Thursday night legends of tomorrow
episode 1 airs I don't know if they're
airing episodes one and two back-to-back
because it's kind of like a two-hour
premiere so there might be two episodes
that night but i'll just i'll keep you
guys posted as i find stuff out and
there is a new round of the reverse
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter that is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video so while
you guys wait for everything to post you
can click here for that Suicide Squad
video from yesterday and you can click
here for all my other Batman V Superman
videos thank you so much for watching
happy new years everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight